[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about the
disruption of decentralized technology
we have Britt Morgan joining us on the
show hello hello thanks for coming on
really appreciate it thank you for
having me I'm so grateful that I
stumbled upon your epicness on the
internet and then was like get on the
show and that you were down to come on I
really enjoyed learning about how
passionate you are about evangelizing
blockchain technology for those that
don't know links in the bio to Britt
Morgan's site blockchain evangelists
been empowering women to learn about the
technology and teaching classes about it
as well also is just super passionate
about the socio-political freedoms that
are going to be occurring with as the
protocols proliferate around the world
which is very exciting stuff this is
applicable to so many things we've been
having tons of conversations with on
blockchain peeps which I'm really
excited for ours let's start things off
on this big history perspective so here
we are as stewards of earth now find
ourselves after this long period of
evolution and we have some exponential
technology stuff happening we have some
8 billion of the almost 8 billion of us
now what are your thoughts on this human
experiment
that's a scope right into that in the
human experience experiment well I think
you know technology is really enabling
you know more freedom to move around the
globe and we're not so tied to these
places where you know we need to be so
globalization is really creating more
freedom to move freely in the globe and
I think blockchain is a part of that and
AI obviously it is a piece of that and
creating movement within this human
experiment
yeah movement this is a T there and so
globalization to your you know to what
you were just voicing this is a very
important piece of the puzzle is being
able to move around the world freely in
a trust-based way as well so that
there's really good indicators that what
you're doing is of strong value and
benevolent and that way you can enter
across borders and all this other kind
of stuff that's very important
interesting that you took us in to
globalization and the movement and
freedom and again it's kind of like
freedom is this theme is that you care a
lot about I mean we all should care a
lot about freedom yes I think we think
you know we know what freedom is
especially you know when we're talking
about the inception of blockchain and
Bitcoin right like we before that we
thought we were living freely and the
kind of interesting we're opened up to
this new way of freedom this new you
know
transaction this new currency which is
really exciting for me personally to
learn about and I think when you can
move money across borders and it's one
Bitcoin is one Bitcoin here and it's one
Bitcoin in India rather than you know
having all of this buildup in tension
between the movement you create more
freedom and so that's just one piece to
all of that just fascinating yeah that
is pretty cool way to put it is that pre
blockchain technologies and the
application of cryptocurrencies with it
that we thought we were free I mean
that's funny it is because you the
baseline was that we are free with money
being controlled by a centralized
government in countries across the world
and then have this trying to trade
across borders be switching currencies
getting getting currency exchange rates
all this kind of stuff yeah hard to do
like if you've ever done it like if
you've ever sent money overseas a lot of
Americans like that we're born here
don't really have that problem but
Americans who come here
and their families overseas they
understand you know how much of their
money is being taken by these
centralized you know institutions right
so it could be 20 percent or 25 percent
if you're if you're driving a taxi or an
uber and you're feeding your family and
you know Central or South America or you
know other parts of the world and you're
sending money to them and that twenty
five percent could could mean a lot or
it does usually I mean 25 percent of any
amount of money that yours is now not
yours because you're sending it does it
really make sense so that's just one
piece that yes why I think it creates
more freedom and then being able to be
put on like your identity
being decentralized as well that you
know that at least your identity being
on on immutable digital Ledger's is
awesome compared to you know someone
coming in and just stripping you away
from your land and you're in your home
and and so identity is also another
interesting one there's like so many of
these applications that's less so
interesting to me but I think like there
are people you know of any ligaments of
ik he's built that you know technology
to put to put people's identity on the
blockchain it's less interesting to me
because I don't see that as a big need
to be solved especially in this country
and yeah and then that's where it's
being implemented I think yeah later on
you can kind of think of identity being
on the I just feel like there's a lot
that could go wrong with that as well
because when you have like a distributed
ledger and that's your identity that's
on it and now it's a transparent ledger
and assuming if it's really on
blockchain that could also be
problematic if people can access that
quite easily so I see some flaws in that
kind of system right now but I mean I'm
sure that like I could be proven wrong I
don't know fully I just like you know I
got instinct on how that would play out
just like it's not like the most obvious
use case I think there's more obvious
use case for the technology like you're
mentioning like titles tool and like you
know there's many countries where you
have like these really long histories
like this this country it's a new
country really like we don't have that
many generations of land ownership right
it might just be four or five but you go
to countries that are really rich in
history where they have you know people
who owned this land for like thousands
of years and they might have they might
show up one day even though you bought
this piece of land and say I actually
own it here's here's the deed and it's
like well what I own this land
and then there's yeah we don't really
have that problem in this country I
think but in other countries it's been
that's not an uncommon thing it's
happened
you know you hear those antidotal pieces
to that problem so I think that could be
a really great use case for the
technology I've read yeah yeah so it's
the you know creating a distributed
ledger of the asset ownership like
things like land especially like you
were saying and in places around the
world
similarly with what this is going to do
with all the different decentralized
applications the way that you know smart
contracts are going to enable us to more
fluidly be able to exchange without
middle peoples is great you know and
well I'm sure we're gonna dive into this
you're you in 2016 ish we're picking up
teaching you were like you were like
hello this technology is amazing and
actually I would suggest learning in
2016 okay I worked at an open source
technology with some of the brightest
systems engineers in the world started
diving into you know software
engineering and like just really what
the what you know Technol
getting deeper into technology itself
and talking to some of the smartest
people about this new thing which you
know was Bitcoin and really going like
hmm these are incredibly intelligent
engineers and they're so fascinated
about this imaginary internet money I
mean that's really what it is even then
and now and so from there I started
learning and learning and learning and
something that you know being in San
Francisco being around you know these
really like the smartest people in the
world I think you know pH ease of
cryptography like you know open source
technologists and engineers and and from
there started learning wow like this is
going to be huge right this already is
huge but it like people don't understand
it like they don't understand
like the implications of what this could
mean the technology behind it right
blockchain but also Bitcoin itself I
still am a big fan of because it really
it really is an interesting way to think
right because it takes you away from
well what if we don't need this
government-issued money and what if we
did know exactly how much was in
circulation and what if we could
transact globally and we didn't have
these restrictions that are placed by
these you know governments right and you
know they're putting all kinds of
tariffs and things on you know beyond
our comprehension because it's so
complicated
from these bureaucratic systems and so
it just became to me like a really
simple solution to a really complicated
and convoluted industry and government
and you know the way we money moves
around the world so that's when I
started becoming really fascinated with
it I started reading everything about
that was published I think even now we
don't really understand the implications
of the technology and if anyone tells
you they're an expert they're probably
not and so I just learned as much as I
could and I wanted to share that with
everyone who would listen and and and
what was interesting as you know I
started talking about the technology and
the investments I made it was men who
wanted to come like you know they were
almost like knocking down the door like
tell me what you know like who's this
and like where should I what I co should
I buy and I'm like God why is it like it
was literally every day because I mean
this is like during the bubble right
like ever all the masses are running
towards this new thing what's like the
new internet or you know everyone's just
so excited about it and I was a woman I
was like where are the women like why
aren't I
why am I just helping all of these men
make easy money because that's
essentially you know any bubble you're
right to make some easy money
well the speculators are going you know
wild which was happening and so I
decided to help women get in
learn about you know not just the
different investments but the technology
behind it and like what I knew and you
know the different philosophies that
could this could unleash as the
technology and so yeah I've been doing
that for a couple years just I it's
probably the cadence of like once a
month small intimate setting and now
I've been doing it virtually and it's
it's really great to talk I mean it just
got it just it's always evolving like to
teach someone something that you're
passionate about and is a gift and I
love doing it I hope I can always do it
whether it's blockchain or whatever is
next in really happy to share the
information that I've learned with with
any men as well but but but like that's
like the genesis of why I like if you've
been on the site it's like yeah like
kind of seems like it's just for women
but it's not like I've obviously will
teach men - yeah yeah and Ron we have
that image of Britta with the at the
conference at the conference table with
three other women where you were doing
kind of like one of these small intimate
teaching sessions exactly and this is
cool learning about your history getting
to this point it's kind of like when
you're there hearing about what the
potential is and you're like whoa we
have so much that we can do with this
around the world to make everything just
decentralized put the power back into
people's hands it's just a very exciting
thing know how much is in circulation
transact around the world it's it's all
it's all extremely exciting it's also
extremely interesting to try and get you
know eight billion people adapted to a
new system of thinking and that's kind
of where you were like okay how can I
get this into more people's hands
nothing that's the only way it really
works I mean and I mean there's been a
lot of comparisons to the 90s and the
internet right and you can you can
actually I mean I wouldn't argue that
this is as powerful is that
era was because the information era of
the Internet boom and everything that
was happening then I think is really
unique and blockchain will will
definitely be disrupting certain
industries but I but there are some
parallels and the parallels that you see
right or at the beginning no one was
really using it it was really when we
were it was to talk on these centralized
you know it wasn't kind of like the
decentralized web it was like we're
using a well to chat with other people
on AOL or you know you probably remember
right and so like it was really archaic
and we were in the style up and things
were happening but we couldn't really
comprehend mm-hmm
how they are now right we're thinking oh
the and you know people that were much
smarter than you know I was a kid then
but you know that people some people
knew that the power that it would
unleash but most people did it and I
think the same is true for this
technology people people don't really
understand including myself yeah I mean
and including myself as well but I still
like I can feel you know when you're in
a room with you little look yeah yeah
you know you know that I do it I like I
like how you you brought us to the
instant messaging days because you know
thinking about it back then when you do
an instant message compared to now when
your you have your you know your email
and your and it's lightning speed and
your and you're always connected to the
Internet and you have your DMS across
your like messenger and all these other
platforms and video and voice video
voice through a click of a button across
the world yeah yeah it's we have like we
can map the whole world like that like
every like the technology that exists
right now compared to when we were kids
yes yes it's mind-blowing right yes you
know people didn't that foresight though
when we were kids was really hard to
have but you know now that we're adults
it's a little easier to have some
foresight into what the decentralization
technologies will bring forth
it at their fullest potential a little
bit more foresight we still don't know
of course I don't I think well what the
promise is right is that it's going to
disrupt these huge monopolies of
centralized companies like you have yeah
I just met with a PhD cryptographer and
Zurich Switzerland and he was talking to
me about what they're working on which
is basically this cloud-based
distributed model right so it's like
replacing AWS which is really
interesting is like when you think about
it it's like well AWS has all the data
right not just AWS like Google as well
and Microsoft but these big centralized
companies they own basically all of the
data that's coming around and when
you're thinking about some data like if
you've ever been on a dating site like
tender there might be some sensitive
vulnerable data that you wouldn't want
other people in the world to know right
and that's sitting in a centralized
server right for AWS or Google cloud
services GCS or Microsoft Azure so those
poor which is that maybe you do want
something like your biometric data to be
open access for institutions to be able
to make better healthcare decisions for
you and for other humans because they're
able to have these data silos be opened
up so that's also kind of like an
interesting dichotomy with that no your
honor
well I'm just thinking of like 23andme
and like that kind of biometric data and
then they're already you know selling
that data to insurance companies which
is not a good thing right because if you
have like some kind of genetic
predisposition to some kind of weird
rare disease and now and you know your
insurance company doesn't want to you
know supply you with insurance because
of they know this new data point I think
so there's the reason I gave you that
look was because I'm like thinking of
that yeah yeah a malevolent case
scenario a lot of a lot of what
you know we in you know one of the
reasons why it's called simulation is
because we do like to run this
experiment in our minds of what would
have been like if civilization kind of
just made sure that every single seed
every single mind that was being birthed
into the world had the right nutrients
was given the right keys to unlock their
own self-actualization and had the right
family had the right like familial
interactions strong parental engagement
all this kind of stuff and if that was
the case I think that it would be much
less likely that we would have
malevolence is occurring as we open up
and become more transparent like
hopefully we can get to a point where we
can be more transparent and more open
rather than needing to be more closed
off and I think that scared that's
amazing yeah transparency and Trust or
at like the center point of connection
parents Ian trust I mean yeah if you
know good luck I think we'll we'll get
there but yeah I mean but like if you're
like if we're bringing break baking it
down right to just like human connection
and we're having this conversation but
we're talking about like you know some
superficial pieces we're not actually
going to create this deep connection but
if we're transparent and you're start to
understand maybe a little bit deeper
about Who I am and what will actually
create a connection and there's like a
lot of psychology pieces do that yeah
yeah I mean now we're talking about
transparency as far as the federal
reserve and how much money is in
circulation that it could also be a
really interesting yeah thing to know
yeah yeah things especially now the way
our mindsets are programmed and maybe
our friend was laughing is that it
doesn't it we can't comprehend that kind
of transparency transparency for
something yes
and maybe that's true like maybe
everything shouldn't be completely open
open source or transparent but we need
to change we need to evolve we need to
become different human beings we need to
be less full of [ __ ]
we need to be self-aware accept who we
are for what we are and leave it at that
good luck yeah the the evolution is a
very you know important key here that
since yourself work again if that seed
gets the right nutrients and doesn't get
birth into the world with trauma and
with a lack of self-actualization just a
stronger social fabric all these types
of things that help with the education
then this transparent trust built
especially with the technology that
enables a lot of decentralization
technology I think we have a lot of
potential for a a trust a trust and
transparent driven society and that's
very exciting to me hugely exciting to
me me too yeah yeah and the applications
are endless for for for the tech like
just thinking about it 25 years from now
like we're talking about you know AOL
and instant messaging compared to what
we have now and what this could be like
trust and transparency down the line
super super exciting yeah yeah it's like
we can't you can't really comprehend
yeah yeah that web of trust right like
just like we can comprehend the web of
information like think about the amount
of information we have you can literally
learn or gain access to everything like
wait and if you sit with someone from a
generation you know like our
grandparents age and you talk to them
about the internet then you just really
start realizing like just how yeah
incredible it is that we're living in
this world right now with the technology
available and how amazing this hopefully
this new technology as it evolves
because it is like I mean
like I said there's a reason Facebook
created a Facebook coin it's for
retention of Engineers because the
smartest people that they have building
you know their systems engineers who you
know are responsible for maintaining the
whole face but now Facebook Network one
until we even go work on blockchain and
crypto currencies so they're like will
that just make our own coin and that's
not like you know they did that because
these are really intelligent people that
understand that this technology is could
really create this new protocol that
changes you know the whole landscape of
everything right so I mean you have to
like and Google's doing the same thing
Google has a whole secret blockchain
department that they're not really
talking about it's because the smartest
people that work there won't it work on
blockchain yeah right and so I think for
me personally it's like there's a reason
people are drawn to this technology that
the the the engineers and the
technologists especially and from the
beginning that's who was really there
you know is the these systems engineers
and and other people understand
programming and also anarchists because
they were like [ __ ] the government you
know like this could solve all our
problems and and so it's like those two
groups of people and then and then
aetherium happened and all these people
did I SEOs and then the spec it of yeah
yeah retail investors came in and then
you know which were more like finance
driven and gamblers and the hustlers and
they came in and now I think what will
happen is gonna even out and we're gonna
have some real change being implemented
I think so too
and it's it's interesting thinking about
it in in waves like that that that a lot
of the core importance of the tech being
able to solve a lot of these challenging
issues that that we have you know tech
is one aspect of solving those issues
and then the social fabric is kind of
like another one of those issues tech
hat helps with the social fabric but
also just like you can't evolve
the someone from their from their from
their own heart I'm making sure that the
seed has the right nutrients that it's
you know social fabric is important but
also making sure the basic needs of
shelter love food electricity etcetera
are all taken care of as well those two
things go hand in hand but then yeah
that with the wave that came in that
kind of made the tech goal it was a gold
rush for the bubble the bubble for them
for the bubble that it was that made it
that was a slight I think detour to
where the potential was but it kind of
has happened throughout yeah
history yeah it happened in the 90s with
the dot-com boom like you know didn't
even happened and yeah in mobile social
as well yeah these like hyped technology
is which blockchain I you know it's way
over hyped but it's still powerful it's
so interesting and so it going to unlock
these things that we can't even really
understand yet because we don't you know
know where that technology is going to
take us happening so I'm super excited
to see what happens yeah it's gonna be
big I think you know the financial
sector is just ripe to be disrupted
because of all the things you mentioned
as far as yeah you know we're you know
in this massive debt right as a country
the government right and if we had more
transparency and to where the money was
moving into what was actually being
funded and to who is actually getting it
as as a you know population I think that
would be a huge huge thing for us and
blockchain and Bitcoin already offer
that kind of solution there's no debt
though it's all a rigged game isn't it
anyway talk about transparency we don't
know why anybody anything it's all
rigged fixed to be enslaved well I mean
they're printing money so yeah if we
just continue to do that is I don't
I can't really imagine that it will
eventually not collapse it is collapsing
those days are over I'm excited to write
keep up the good work we're all counting
on you
this is so this is a you know this is
one of the the the primary ways of us
retrieving our own sovereign tree as
individuals and also as building a
stronger social fabric this is one of
the ways - one of the applications is
through money there's a lot of you know
in the last image that we had I'm just
imagining the way that you're talking to
and empowering different women and
different leaders and just having these
conversations with them where what were
these central sort of principles that
you were teaching about when you were
having these conversations so I think
there's so many different pieces when
you're talking about blockchain and we
discussed that earlier like you know you
have to have a little bit of econ you
need to understand programming just a
little bit because really that's what
the the Bitcoin blockchain is it's like
if you're gonna if you're really when it
want to invest in this you should have a
little bit of understanding of
incentives models of game theory of you
know governance so we talk about all of
those things I really tried to like get
them empower them to do their own
research because yep the last thing I
want to do is tell anyone to go invest
in anything that they don't fully
understand because it ultimately when
you're investing or or deciding to like
research something it should be because
you want to and so I'm just trying to
plant the seed and have them you know
water it and grow whatever they want
because really it is about sovereignty
and independence and like understanding
something yourself right and so there's
a lot of resources out there and like I
said like this is the beginning of
what this technology is going to do so
if you could you know see like yes a
bubble just happened right in 2017 the
whole everything was inflated and I
think a lot of that was market makers
and a lot of that was you know people
coming in that were just following the
masses instead of understanding what was
actually happening
and kind of seeing like the trends of a
bubble which like art we're always you
know kind of susceptible to being
victims of you want to go on I could
tell you just let it out I have the lack
of sleep is still hitting me at times
yeah definitely yep but yeah so so yeah
I mean III all I do is try to like and
empower these people to do their
research and like point them in the
right direction because there are some
things out there that aren't you know
the right information right there's a
lot of there's thousands of different
crypto currencies that makes it really
hard yeah a lot of them aren't even
blockchain based right they yeah yeah
they're centralized yeah they're not
open source so I open sourced yeah so
I'm just like a steward of yeah
believing in the and in this technology
and kind of hoping that it does do the
best thing for everyone
this is this is very important as you
indicate that you know with thousands of
of potential cryptocurrencies some that
are centralized some that are not
open-source that really taking it by the
horns and doing your own research and
understanding governance game theory
economics programming just even in the
tiniest bits yeah yeah are crucial in in
being able to then further go into
communities and and help other people
get inspired about it and then get
involved this this in a sense it's also
kind of like as as so many things are
they follow a principle of like the
Pareto distribution and it just seems as
though there's going to be a similar
outcome where a little majority of
people concentrate into just a couple of
the exchange methods there is like an
all there's an alternative potential
where ever where humans are in the
interacting with different
cryptocurrencies for every different
thing that they're doing which is like
you either use one for everything or you
use millions for every little different
thing that you do those seem like two of
the more common ways of of where this is
heading yeah I don't think we need
millions of them to transact I think
there are some interesting use cases so
like create a token but personally it
doesn't make sense it's not a viable
solution I think anytime you're looking
at blockchain it should solve a problem
like there's a lot of problems that we
have with with a lot of different
sectors and industries and so if you're
thinking about applying a blockchain
solution to a business or an whole
industry like it should be to solve a
problem right and so not to just create
it no I that's my personal
and although that is like an evolved
opinion initially like I did I did think
that that could work you know I did I
was a believer that okay we can tokenize
everything which is you know maybe I
thought that that might be a great
solution to like incentivize people to
do the right thing even or to have to
you know have a kind of a fixed behavior
and a certain platform or you know if
you're gonna if you're taking you know
the shared economy right and you're
decentralizing it and then you're
incentivizing people through a token so
like you know Airbnb there's already
there's actually a company and you're
doing like decentralize there are B&B
it's called beat betoken mhm and so
that's interesting but it's also I don't
think it's viable at least yet and so
because it's like how do we how do we
have all of these tokens in a way that
makes sense for us as people to easily
yeah transact right so the example would
be you would lease your place on betoken
and then someone would come in in
exchange their currency for your spot to
stay and then you would earn a B token
that you could go in exchange for
whatever else you want on the exchanges
so I don't think it's quite like that
but similar so the way I understand it
as people list their properties on the U
token platform which is decentralize the
platform right and so there's a token
that's being that's built on the
blockchain and in order to unlock the
place you you buy the token like if you
wanted to say that ever with their
beautiful currency so then you would
exchange your currency for a be token
then used to be token to unlock the
property and there's so many and the
person would get to be token that owns
the property then they could do what
they want with that B token so that's
kind of the millions of tokens versus
the so there's so many friction points
it sounds like to me
initially I was like this seems like an
amazing idea because what you're doing
is you're bringing power back to the
people literally right it's a difference
between just using a normal Airbnb or
what's the difference between using like
a Bitcoin or and ether or whatever yeah
I know I got a difference but I mean so
they've created a native token that's
how they would make money right that's
how yeah as far as I understand I mean
I'm I'm only I've only I've read their
white paper before they launched and I
know that they've launched and they have
properties on there so they are like a
working use case of this like tokenized
society but I don't fully a motley yeah
this is this is a really interesting
example of kind of like friction points
versus versus not I mean it does seem as
though if if I was living in a very
frictionless but millions of
cryptocurrencies world that I could just
very easily have a wallet that could
transfer to whatever cryptocurrency I
want yeah and then be able to engage
with that with that just very
frictionlessly and then they can be
built yeah I think eventually it might
make sense but right now to me it
doesn't
yeah so it could write in an alternative
just seems as though it it's just on a
on a on a single decentralized managed
by everyone that and for constant review
constant updating platform that it just
makes it easy and then there's and then
what goes I guess what goes past
cryptocurrency and to so many people's
thoughts is having the the serious AI
robotic transition that makes it makes
money completely irrelevant which is
another very interesting thought as well
how is that I would like to hear oh just
like such ubiquity and everything and
just you know nanotechnology enabling
that just you know nuclear fusion
enabling the unlimited and abundant
energy there's just like massive amount
of components to that and it's just like
very far out but it's it's kind of like
cryptocurrency can sometimes be like a
like a kind of like a middle point
potentially to that and even like
everything you just said it like because
it's like it's very it's very it's very
weird things like you have to be fusing
is to be doing nuclear fusion to get
energy then you have to be empowering
the the material manufacturing of things
like robots to be doing things like
harvesting planting and harvesting food
and then you know and then there again
powered through fusion solar so many
different ways and then having that be
brought to humans that are you know you
just order whatever you want every
single day and there's such ubiquity
that can just be delivered to you no
problem
there's my drones by drones there's
power better yeah and then and then and
then that's you know that's you know but
then the questions come like who's
incentivized to make the robotic and
drone and AI systems and fusion systems
if if everyone is equal and if there's
there's lots of other questions that
arise with this do you mean these these
sorts of like utopic pictures are very
difficult to make because there well
there will be no utopian future get over
it it will always be a dark villain be
with the force Alan I mean maybe the
next you know
generation of humans could be more
utopian they won't be called humans yeah
yeah with an ex homo that would you dote
Indy bio the German I forgot
but yeah sapiens with an X is
interesting humans augmented yeah that's
what uh mi t--'s Brandon shout out to
Sarah nooshin MIT we like you guys a lot
yeah yeah so this again it's like
there's this far out long now
perspective of what humanity is like in
you know couple you know a hundred years
or whatever is happening versus like
just twenty years or so and then versus
like tomorrow and there's like yeah
these stepping stones along the way and
a lot of what your you know what you're
doing is kind of in that tomorrow to
some decade maybe or two down the line
trying to get people thinking about what
this is gonna be yeah I mean so one of
the projects that I am an advisor on
it's called Agora and they do voting on
the blockchain they actually facilitated
you know an election in Sierra Leone so
if you're thinking about I mean here
yeah I was going to say here we don't
have that problem but we do right we
have election fraud and and scandals and
and corruption but there it's like very
prevalent in certain parts of the world
and so you know this technology really
could enable a more just society when
you're talking about putting blockchain
in a decentralized trustless way where
these elections have historically been
rigged you know by aggression and money
and things you know of that nature and
sort of the good of the people and so I
think there's a lot of things that are
already happening right now that could
change the world for the better and make
you know places like Sierra Leone and
other countries in the world that have
these really massive and justices that
we just were so fortunate and to not
have to deal with and so yeah I mean
it's already it's already like happening
right that this new this technology is
already doing a lot of really good work
it's just not being talked about on a
skill or way that that a lot of the
other technology like drones and AI and
this automated thing is yeah
I think walk us through the example of
the Tekken Sierra Leone so when you so
there there has to be two things with an
electron thanks Ron yeah go ahead what
was that
prepare to die Oh prepare the asteroid
is faster it's coming it's like the
warning fun basically like when for
Agoura the the tech the the blockchain
has to be completely decentralized so
it's like but you also have to have a
way for them to transact so there's a
centralized piece which is like the
platform that sits on top of of the
blockchain so those two pieces are
intersecting and creating this trustless
way to have a transparent and just and
actually like democratic election so
yeah I mean that's that's just one piece
but there's a lot of difficulty when
you're going into countries that have a
lot of violence and you're you're saying
you're gonna help facilitate an election
there right it is usually what happened
usually there's two parties and they
don't like each other and they use
aggression and fear and sometimes you
know murder and things like that so it's
kind of a very delicate thing that is
happening with with this company and
which is probably why you know it's
we're not talking about it also right
I'm talking about now but yeah it is a
very delicate thing because you want to
stay neutral it has to be neutral you
don't want it anyone to think you're you
care about one side or the other when
you have these bipartisan you know
governments all over the world that they
could really benefit from these
technologies technology so this
technology is specifically what was the
centralized piece that lives with the
decentralized so that would be just like
the technology piece so this the boding
can take place on the phone or in a
booth and that you know obviously that
is owned by
oh so it's and then they're submitting
to the decentralized okay yes so then
it's sent onto the blockchain but the
votes are actually okay but it's so like
Ron and gotcha through a centralized
yeah okay okay but then at least there
is a decentralized yeah that vote yeah
it's not being in a transparent
trustless way on the blockchain okay
yeah yeah as long as there's not I mean
any corruption happening in the
centralized layer then yeah yeah yeah
which that's that's the hard thing yeah
how do you come in and say facilitating
an election processes yeah and there's
again but I'm excited about that project
yeah yeah that's an interesting one
there's again this seems as though it's
constantly comes back to humans having
basic needs met humans having baselines
of living just increased enabling them
to have more time to think critically
about the world instead of just be
looking for the next meal and looking
for the next these these things inhibit
the seeds from fully and flourishing the
hierarchy of needs right yeah first have
the baseline you know physical aspects
met before you can think about the you
know what even the world is and all that
we're so privileged I agree yeah a
hundred percent we're so [ __ ] proven
language yeah sitting here kids watch my
niece watches this show oh no we are
yeah we are we're ridiculously
ridiculously grateful yeah I'm right now
going through you know this I mentioned
you this immigration process and yeah
I'm trying to move to Switzerland which
is very exciting it's very exciting but
I'm starting to you know have just a
little bit a pain with that and
realizing wow like I've been so
privileged to just move around the world
you know I have a America I have a
passport I can go to most countries in
the world without even having to go get
a visa right
but then now I'm in this position where
I have to let go through this process of
emigrating into this country that's very
hard to immigrate into and it's it's
it's an interesting place to be so when
when when you're the one that has
difficulties getting into another
country yeah that's very yeah very
important of I'm thinking behind eyes of
people that yeah 100% like I came back I
was just in Switzerland I came back just
to do this no I did yeah yeah I came
back just to see my family and do some
meetings here and yeah I just really
felt a lot of empathy
I mean I've I've I've had the empathy
but now it's really like or I've had
maybe some sympathy but now I have the
empathy towards people trying to
immigrate to this country this is your
up or honk are using Ford surgeries yeah
this is yamas yeah so it's crazy it's
interesting it's it feels very archaic
to me to have the yes yes yes four days
let's see then this could this takes us
to the again if the if the if the data
flows are decentralized then they're
transparent and there's not malevolent
actors then it's easy to know Oh Britt
Morgan look currently I'm going to
Switzerland for a period of time maybe
she's gonna live there for a couple
years whatever that that that this data
that there's no malevolent actors trying
to map when you leave somewhere so they
could break into your place so you don't
really care if you're if your blip is
visible on the on the radar where you're
going and
they see these are this is the kind of
world that I hope in some K in some in
some ways like that your biometrics are
constantly being monitored and that if
there's a potential pathology that's
starting the form right away that you're
being assisted with that and in the
preventive medicine that's what yeah
yeah yeah but but then for example but
that data is available to everyone but
there's no malevolent actor so for
example I like if my biometrics are
available all the time I'm never worried
that someone's gonna see a specific way
that they can hack into me and and try
and cause harm but that these open data
flows make it easier to crunch and and
predict the pathologies prior to them
emerging and causing harm so these are
this is just one of many ways that if we
can really evolve from the heart and get
the right nutrients to every seed and
prevent malevolent actors from forming
that we can live in a complete
transparent trusted society interesting
ok so that's how I guess ok so I guess
finally at least we got to that what ok
cool cool ok it's hard to evolve there I
think it would have been easier if we
started at the 1 million human mark and
went for that instead of starting at the
8 billion human mark and trying to get
to that ok teach us about Switzerland
quick so Switzerland is obviously a very
like financial hanging there's neutral
Haven like what do we when we think of
Switzerland we think of chocolate and we
think of banks right and we think of
like a neutral place right yeah and it I
mean it's all those things but they I
think it's interesting like being there
you really feel like they preserved this
culture right you don't have this like
consumeristic way of life like we're
like using these disposable things all
the time and buying whatever we need on
Amazon at a click of a button things
aren't really accessible like that there
you have to like go to a place and
and you know pay a decent amount of
money what it's probably worth and I
think you talk to a person to get
whatever it is such a person but yeah I
mean there's several fascinating things
about the country that are that I really
like I like that they've been able to
kind of maintain for the most part with
the exception of a few occurrences a
neutral stance yeah you know which has
allowed them to be the you know at the
center of some of these really big
institutions that play a part and
creating a more humane world right like
the UN is positioned in Switzerland
which is like we all know you know
trying to make the world like yeah
you're a better place United Nations and
like a good government governance model
of how we're looking at things so from a
blockchain perspective when we're
talking about the movement of trust like
it makes sense for for Switzerland to
kind of take the lead and create you
know some of the governance pieces to
what will be you know the the the
transaction the trust transactions of
blockchain so yeah there's so many
pieces there there's one of them that I
thought was so interesting was I'm just
curious how much money is spent in
Switzerland on defense versus just in
like in the United States just taking
the 800 billion dollars in a more
trusted world and putting that all
towards education across all these
countries that have defense budgets also
kind of stuff also another thing you
indicated that was interesting was just
a decrease in consumerist culture that's
very interesting that if the social
fabric around you is less consumerist
oriented then you're gonna have a lower
tendency to want to go and and then buy
things it's like more about people
nature conversations education only
these types of things this would get me
very interested yeah there you're making
like you're making people interested in
wanting to go there
I mean well then it really would I don't
know how special will be like that I
really like like being over there and
hope I can say I'm still I don't have a
visa so I'm as I go it's like as a
tourist for now so I'm working on that
Keith's which yeah do you ski or
snowboard yes so I ski yeah this is good
good skiing up there but you know I grew
up here as a surfer so that it's
landlocked
there so I have that kind of issue yeah
well you got the surfing skier do you
know dick do anything no no yo he's a
guitarist from like the 50 60s that you
know had that surf sound he just
recently passed away
oh go back to your regularly in the
Mediterranean I think that is not really
also that like I guess those massive
surf vibes no but it's good really good
vibes good vibes good
I'm talking about surfing this
conversation exactly I knew she was a
surfer we met and talked about surfing
that's another thing I'm really
passionate about is the ocean and good
in blockchain and surfing and yeah I
mean the ocean is like I know
sonofa zone so you know I know and
there's so much beauty in what we don't
know about the depths of what's going on
I mean it's like our life force it is a
really big part of how the earth
stabilizes yeah yeah and we're not just
to it at all that's right um going back
into talking about consumerism and like
you know the problem that we have there
which is ending up in the ocean and you
know that's like been a huge fascination
of mine and I think my next you know as
an entrepreneur and my next project I
would really love to do some work as far
as the ocean goes and I know there are
some projects that I've I've just been
talking to people in San Francisco about
which are creating governance for the
ocean and tying yeah having the supply
chain of like where did it come from
where this plastic come from and you
know why
ending up in the Pacific Garbage Patch
oh I mean we know why it's because we're
buying all this stuff that's not
sustainable right we buy it and then we
throw it away or we go and we go get
some food and we take it to go we're not
really like we have some going all the
way back to the biodegradable 's in the
first place is the plastics though it's
just this the speed at which right now
it's cranking out the the plastics
versus the slow down and make it in all
biodegradable that can actually degrade
in a day yeah yeah and there's so many
different ways to to make it happen you
don't have to say no okay okay couple
quick I'm glad that you're passionate
about that as well this is this has been
very exciting Britain I mean exciting we
all should be yeah everyone should
really start thinking about how they're
consuming everything like if you're more
intentional to like like I yeah that's
right I have like a fork and it struck
like I have I try to be really what's
cool because I mean it's like hippy or
whatever but yeah but it how hard is it
to just carry it around it's not hard at
all like oh well when you have like a
little bag it's easier than one you're
like trying to carry fork in your pocket
yeah I mean it doesn't always happen a
knotek also is a good thing that enables
you to very quickly be able to
transition this into a fork or
transition it into whatever you need Oh
which is yeah it's all it's all very
like you know future futuristic I'm
exciting I know I know
thanks for thanks for pulling that up
it's very it's important for us to
together to get a reminder that Mother
Earth is you know fighting us off with
why don't we do things like that
quick two quick questions on the way up
this is simulation so we got to ask you
are we in a simulation sure if we want
to be I think like our perception is
reality so if you think you're in a
simulation then you might be but I
personally am like living in a very
crazy reality right now so no I'm not in
a simulation but maybe you are and
that's cool or maybe it's just a crazy
simulation oh yeah crazy simulation but
no I don't think so
okay and the last questions what do you
think the most beautiful thing in the
world
hmm I mean the ocean I'm really like I'm
a sailor and surfer and just being out
there and seeing like and feeling the
energy of all the life underneath it and
yeah it's so beautiful yeah it's great
and now I'm like do I really want to go
live in a land like explain yeah yeah
yeah yeah the ocean what about you I'm
curious oh oh that's a that's a great
answer the the ocean there's so much
yeah I'm the one that asks the questions
no no that's it's thank you for asking
thank you for asking back um yeah this
I'm I don't know there's there's there's
so many answers but the fact that life
evolved here on this rock and that were
able to to have a meta thought on it yes
it's just very fun it's beautiful it's
it's very fun and yeah it's it's it's
just like it's just it's enjoyable you
know so let's enjoy you know the life
that we have and endure best to bring
value to other people and totally in
transition to cool technologies like the
decentralize technologies then
blockchain are enabling and continue
proliferating the knowledge across the
world Britt thank you for coming on and
thank you for having me
really really like love job being here
good I'm so happy to hear that and we
loved having you there was so much
goodness that I think can be further
passed along and so you know this is
what we do on the show if you guys had a
good time let us know your thoughts in
the comments below if you didn't have a
good time
silence no I'm kidding tell us whatever
we would love to hear again your
thoughts like go and proliferate to
surround the world get more people
talking about blockchain get more people
talking about decentralized technologies
what that means to us across all the
applications
check out Britt's links in the bio below
check out all her links go and give her
a follow huge shout out to Ron for
producing and directing we love you very
much thank you and support the artists
and entrepreneurs that you believe in
across the world go and support them in
your communities and around the world
our links are below if you believed in
us we need your help growing as well and
go and build everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you so
much and we will see you soon
peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]